is there an evolutionary benefit to
being offended or being offendable i can
think of nothing else in the universe
that is offendable only us humans i do
not use no i do not see any benefit to
this attribute but maybe i'm missing
something if it is indeed in that
negative perhaps instead of trying to
eliminate everything considered
offensive humanity should indeed instead
strive to become so offensive that
people are no longer offendable would
love to get your thoughts on this so i'm
going to let you riff but first i will
say with regard to anything else in the
universe
being offendable
um other primates get offended you can
you can see this um like baboons and
certainly the other apes
when
when there's a breach of the hierarchy
or of the food sharing rules or
or some such and because we are so
closely related to them
we can see this in their sort of shared
facial expressions and as such i imagine
that although it'd be less hard to
less easy it will be more difficult to
tell
with organisms that share
fewer of our
sort of social cues but some of the
other long-lived generational overlap
social long childhood organisms like
elephants like wolves like dolphins like
parrots like crows i'll bet give and
take offense but you know what would how
would you know when a dolphin i don't i
don't know you know we've known people
who spent time studying the social
behavior of dolphins and maybe they
would know but certainly it wouldn't
show up the same way as it does on us
because they have a different
um
we have we have a most recent common
ancestor with dolphins it's a long way
back and before we ended up with um
quite so many of the facial muscles that
we have
yes
i know there's a good joke and how would
you know if a dolphin was offended i i
am not quick enough on the draw today um
all right so you know you get to the
meat of the question right well let me
just say yeah you're right about uh
other primates showing offense slow
lorises in particular
yeah they're very quick to anger in many
circumstances it's amazing they actually
managed to petition to get the name slow
loris it's sort of a it's a bait and
switch you meet one you're like wow that
was
i didn't expect that from you slow loris
right exactly um yeah we actually have
not been lucky enough to meet any slow
lorises laura all right lorax
no that's a different thing okay um
yeah obviously a fence is adaptive it
passes the adaptive test with flying
color i will say obviously it is it
should be presumed to be adaptive it
could be a byproduct of something that
is adapted but clearly adaptive
evolution built it
and given its nature as a cognitive
phenomenon it would be so easy to purge
it from a person and you would get a lot
of advantage out of not being offendable
so clearly the advantage of being
offendable must outweigh the advantage
of not being offendable otherwise it
would go away rapidly
so what's the what's the point well
all emotions are a proxy landscape
for
uh
calculations about what one should and
shouldn't do in other words the sum
total of all the calculations of your
perception of where you are
socially environmentally and all the
rest
gives you a guide for how to
act right you find something you know uh
tantalizing and you go towards it and
you find something horrifying and you
recoil and um that's how we function
right we are not automatons we
function based on the sort of comparison
of these values and they lead us to
overcome our fears or to you know be
dominated by them or however it works
but
the point is
offense is part of a calculus if you're
talking about offense not like an
offensive smell but if you're talking
about being offended at somebody's
comment for example
then what you are doing is you are
creating something in the neighborhood
of an imagined
uh
debt right when somebody offends you
what it means is something beyond i
disagree with what you said
but i am troubled by the implications of
the fact that you said it right
so um you know a racist comment for
example
may indicate that somebody harbors a
belief system
that i don't know imagines that their
population has inherent superiority
right so you would take offense at it
and the point is that offense
then
uh i think the point of defense is a bit
durable
when you say you are offended what you
mean is five minutes from now this is
not going to have
vanished because time has passed
the point is i'm actually noting that
and i'm making a kind of permanent note
that it is an indicator of something and
it might be that it takes three or four
such notes to really realize yeah this
person does have a defective model in
their mind compared to what i think
reality looks like after a certain
number of iterations you go from i'm
offended to i think you're offensive at
least to me
yeah you do and the point is it adjusts
your context maybe the point is well i'm
hardly going to trust this person with
such calculations or i don't think they
can be trusted with power or
resources or something like that but
anyway it's part of an accounting scheme
is the basic point and it is it i think
it has a connotation of durability which
suggests that this is not a momentary
it's not like um you know when somebody
bumps into you on the subway right
you're not offended they may in fact
have been callous but the point is it's
a very temporary
thing the offense is durable inherently
and i think that indicates something
about it
[Music]